-Finally, before we go, I'd like
to take a moment
to thank some of our sponsors
for tonight's show.
They don't always fit in the
commercial breaks and we want to
make sure we mention
all of them.
So it's time for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show sponsors ♪
♪ Tonight Show sponsors ♪
-PetSmart.
Do you have a ponytail
and wear cargo shorts?
If so, the lizards are that way.
[ Applause ]
DraftKings.
Come on, your kids don't need to
go to college.
[ Applause ]
Adobe.
Hey. Hey. Hey you.
Hey. Hey. Hi. Hey you.
Hey, it's time for
another update.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Vizio TVs.
Are we a good brand? Who knows?
But look! Big!
[ Applause ]
Oreo Thins --
Just like regular Oreos,
but you're allowed to eat
30 of them.
[ Applause ]
Fruity Pebbles.
Look, kids, it's based on your
favorite cartoon from the '50s.
[ Applause ]
Sharpie -- In your hand for a
moment, on your hand forever.
[ Applause ]
Pringles.
Come for the chips, stay because
your arm is stuck in the tube.
[ Applause ]
And finally, Marshalls,
somehow flying under the radar
while T.J. Maxx takes
all the heat.
That's it for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."